the generation of the Internet the Iraq
and Afghanistan wars and of course the
Back to the Future series we are the
Millennials and the media loves to call
us lazy and narcissistic and
self-obsessed and even deluded I am here
with three Millennials today in the
flesh not via Skype with me is Parker
from the Electronic Frontier Foundation
Sabiha from design action collective and
Justin from Dropbox all right guys
Parker are we a narcissistic generation
I don't think we're any more
narcissistic than any generation but I
think that there's there may be more
dialog now or conversation about
ourselves and that's not necessarily a
bad thing do you think though that
technology might make us more apathetic
these technology making us lazy when we
have something at the touch of a button
not at all because like everyone's
saying here it's a tool so we can use
that tool for entertainment for doing
our errands and we can also use it to
communicate with each other and stay
more even more civically engaged than we
may have been otherwise vine and these
tools are places where people who don't
have access to larger media centers will
be able to share their points of view
and that's very powerful how do you
respond to the fact that 57 percent of
Millennials engage in political activity
via social media and nothing else
if you flip that around and say that 57%
of Millennials are talking about
politics and political issues in their
community that that's significant one of
the communities that has been using this
to to tremendous effect are feminists
and especially feminists of color who
have these conversations it often it
will center around a hashtag and then
they get reports in the media by you
know the New York Times in the
Washington Post and the major outlets
and then that has a real policy impact
do you think that those same 57% would
let's say go to a protest I don't think
that's actually a useful gauge I think
that there's a lot of different ways to
be politically engaged and some people
want to march in the streets and some
people don't but that doesn't mean that
people that don't march in the streets
are any less committed or effective as
far as being a voice in their community
so given that most Millennials will
struggle and are do not own a home when
let's say their parents were able to put
a down payment when they were let's say
20 years old and given that the job
market is pretty precarious what are
your thoughts on sort of the future for
millennials economically and maybe your
own situations you know I think there's
this kind of it's part of the American
Dream it's like oh I need to own a home
and I need to and and maybe that might
not be the case for this generation you
know maybe it's okay if you don't buy a
home maybe you renting is okay for you
maybe maybe you're in a position where
you want to travel you want to be in
different places all the time having
that house doesn't necessarily mean you
know you've achieved this
I guess quote-unquote American Dream in
a way and we are seeing people be very
creative in alternative and alternative
solutions to career home family still
holding onto our own values and not not
just going with whatever an institution
already has laid out for us people are
figuring out creative creative you know
housing situations with you know
collective home buying so there's
there's a lot of alternatives that are
being explored because the the
structures are so rigid and difficult
right now and that's very exciting too
between 18 and 34
say hello to never buying a house what
do you do now I have three jobs now
what's your retirement plan looking like